as a specialty flow assurance consulting
company we're always looking to
differentiate ourselves and the Wolfram
language has given us the ability to do
that my name is Eric Smith I work for
assured flow solutions in Houston Texas
and we are a flow assurance consulting
company assured flow solutions believes
that you need to have really three
specialties to do the flow assurance
correctly one is the flow assurance
engineering with industry software a
second piece is laboratory analysis and
then the third piece that kind of ties
those two together is the technology
which we've decided to use the Wolfram
technologies for one of the ways Wolfram
language has really showed its value and
the industry is separating problems or
making the problem smaller right now we
run industry software that's very
expensive and when really all we need to
do is calculate the cooldown of a
pipeline we can use the finite element
package and the Wolfram language to do
that for small pieces of pipeline we're
going to very quickly have a much better
understanding by doing a parameter
analysis in the Wolfram language it
takes a few seconds compared to ours and
one of the industry standard software
packages
we have this laboratory with all this
data coming in we'd like to have some
kind of automatic collection of that
data bring it into a database be able to
query that database if we can do that
then we can take current oil samples
over chemical injection samples and
compare them with other results that
we've had in the past right now to
search through that data and to pull it
out
it'd just be too too laborious it takes
too many man-hours to do that so we
don't have it that the Wolfram language
we believe can collect all that data
curate it in some meaningful way and
then we can include that in our analysis
to our clients system monitor on its own
does a lot of the heavy lifting so a lot
of the causality relationships between
components making sure pressures are
equalized that mass is conserved that
energy is conserved that all happens
automatically in the solver it's it's
the fundamentals of system modeler and I
think a lot of engineers have to work a
long time to get that correct and it's a
small alerts it's their out of the box
in terms of integration being able to
script my configurations right a little
bit of code and have system model or
model running with a push of a button is
it's pretty great because then I can do
parameter studies on the configuration
or parameter studies of the inputs and
then again process all of that in a
notebook for an end
so we can pull in the raw outputs from
our pipeline simulations we can take the
pressures temperatures flow rates and
output a kmz file where you can then
view those properties and like a google
Earth's and see the temperatures change
according to the values the pressures
temperatures flow rates so we created a
CDF front-end employees in the lab they
can enter their values into that sheet
they can upload images whatever we
either use an excel template or push
directly to excel we use calm objects
the Wolfram language to write and
manipulate the spreadsheet directly and
then when we output it it's ready to
print and it looks you know all
formatted correctly and all the
calculations behind the scenes here are
done correctly yeah a lot of the
industry packages use text files for
configuration so they're really powerful
tools in the Wolfram language to parse
that information manipulate it send it
back to the file and then maybe even
execute directly from a notebook on the
output side we parse all the outputs -
then we can do math on the results
without having to touch a spreadsheet I
have to make fewer assumptions and I can
deliver a much more rigorous solution to
our clients and the tools that are
available are state of the art and so I
don't have to worry about creating my
own numerical solvers or my own
importing import functions or any
analysis packages it is unique for a
company to embrace technologies that are
different from the standard I think it's
paying off because it seems it seems to
be the smart thing to do we can do a lot
more with a lot less